in the opening scene we see Spain
descending into chaos as a severe crisis
grips Europe leading to shortages of
basic necessities as a result of a
tyrannical government the regime called
not enough for all takes place in order
to cope with this crisis the government
initiates a deadly measure extermination
of the elderly at first and eventually
pregnant women and children some Nations
such as Ireland Iceland and Norway stand
against this brutality so many people
are trying to escape to those lands
however doing this legally is almost
impossible prompting people to resort to
Illegal means among many people we are
introduced to a married couple Nico and
Mia who are trying to leave Spain via
illegal means they bribe a human
trafficker to smuggle them to a local
Harbor for escape the couple then makes
their way through shipping containers
hiding from the authorities and their
monitoring helicopters along the way
they come across another Smuggler who
demands more money the couple is has
already offered all of their money so
they are forced to sacrifice their
wedding rings following this they are
allowed to board a trucks container that
will transport them to the port Nico's
plan is to escape to Ireland by being
transported on a cargo ship once inside
the truck they find themselves among
other desperate people including
pregnant women like Mia and other
families with children however no one
talks to one another as they are
consumed by their own concerns during
this Nico presents Mia with a chocolate
urging her to save it for later to
celebrate their rescue it'll melt you
dumbass says Mia through their
conversation we learned that the couple
had tragically lost their firstborn
daughter as she was shot by the military
in the morning the truck abruptly stops
and a crowd of people forcibly enter as
the truck gets overloaded the Smugglers
order the people split in half and get
on another truck when the people resist
they threaten them with guns and force
them out sadly Nico and Mia get
separated in this process as he is
loaded onto another truck trck container
scared Mia immediately contacts her
husband via phone and Nico tells her not
to worry he assures her that they'll
reunite later because the trucks are
going towards the same destination the
truck then drives through the streets
where people are protesting against the
violence Mia peeps through a hole in the
container and Witnesses the authorities
mercilessly killing the rioter and
taking the women and children away after
some time the truck stops at a military
checkpoint and the officers instruct the
driver to open the container the driver
ner nously complies allowing the
officers to investigate at first they
only find some boxes inside the
container as the escapees are all hiding
behind a false wall however the leader
notices that the container appears
larger from outside and concludes that
there's a secret compartment believing
that the fugitives are hiding inside he
instructs them to come out or face dire
consequences fearing imminent danger Mia
hastily climbs up to a tall wooden crate
and hides herself while other women
reluctantly open the door moments later
the the officers open fire killing the
entire group Mia clenches her mouth
trying hard not to make any sound after
this the soldiers clean up the container
and release the truck Mia then instantly
sends a voice message to Nico warning
him that his truck is going to be
checked next a while later Mia's
container is loaded onto a ship upon
learning that she's arrived at the Port
she tries to contact her husband but
fails to reach him hence she decides to
take some rest and eventually falls
asleep hours later Mia is awake Ed by
sudden jolts peering through a hole she
sees the sailors in a state of chaos as
the ship goes through a huge sea storm
Mia cries out for help begging to be
released but no one can hear her the
container continues to shake causing her
to fall numerous times at one point a
strong jolt causes her to hit her head
rendering her unconscious sometime later
Mia wakes up only to Discover Water
seeping into the Container through holes
in a perplexed State she looks through a
hole and Witnesses the the other
containers slowly sinking into the water
panicked she desperately attempts to
call Nico but her phone is now damaged
just then she finds a bag left behind by
a fellow traveler which contains a
working phone however she doesn't know
the passcode to make a call seeing the
water flowing inside through the holes
She searches through the crates in hopes
of finding a solution the crates hold
various items such as plastic boxes
earphones flat screen TVs vka and more
she also finds hoodies and puts one on
upon further inspection she comes across
some yellow tape which she uses to seal
the holes shortly after Mia is going
through her photo diary when she hears
screaming voices from outside looking
through the hole she Witnesses Nico's
container sinking this deeply frightens
her and she screams her husband's name
repeatedly she also inserts her SIM card
into the working phone but the call
doesn't go through overcome with grief
Mia breaks down in tears as she watches
the containers sink while she's Mourning
her husband's death Mia stumbles upon a
pen knife and contemplates doing the
unthinkable but right then she feels a
kick from her unborn child which prompts
her to reconsider her decision she then
intends to live for her baby and lays
down with tears in her eyes the next
morning Mia wakes up to find the tape
sealing the holes has come off and water
is again flowing inside following this
she pushes a crpe beneath another
hanging one and uses her knife to
release it she opens it only to discover
more plastic boxes this initially
infuriates her but she soon realizes
that the rubber of those plastic
containers can be used to cover the
holes after doing so MIA uses a pipe to
throw away the water from inside she
then checks her supplies and plans to
use them in an Optimum way after 2 days
Mia receives a call from an unknown
number and much to her relief it's from
n he informs her that the driver has
abandoned them outside the city and that
it'll take some time for him to catch up
with with her Mia then confides that
she's stuck in the middle of the ocean
which worries him obviously nevertheless
he promises that he'll come up with a
plan I mean it sounds like you're
probably honey but I'm going to
do what I I'm going to we'll see that
night the container goes through another
storm making it difficult for Mia to
maintain her balance to worsen the
situation she begins to experience labor
pains as the water shakes the container
Mia's pain continues to rise she tries
to call her husband but the phone slips
from her hand with no her choice she
takes off her clothes holds on to The
Container ropes and eventually gives
birth to a baby girl following this Mia
carries her baby and gets in a crate
waiting for the storm to pass if that
baby survives it'll grow up to become
Thor the following morning Mia cleans up
the space and uses the hoodies as
diapers for her baby she tries to care
for her child as best she can but the
infant refuses to eat and continues to
cry in the midst of this Mia Hears A
squeaking sound and has an idea she uses
a drilling machine to create holes in
the ceiling hoping to make an opening
however the noise only makes the baby
cry prompting her to stop that evening
her breasts finally begin to locate what
and she feeds her child before putting
her to sleep at night she gets
overwhelmed by hunger and as a result
she ends up finishing all the food she
has in the morning she continues
drilling the ceiling Mia is about to
finish when unfortunately the machine's
battery dies she then proceeds to cut it
using the pen knife however she can't
carry on for much longer as the
exhaustion overcomes her inside the
container it's very hot and there's
limited air to breathe due to this she
wets the cloth with the sea waterer and
helps her child with heat as the time
passes the situation only worsens
because Mia now has nothing to eat when
hunger becomes unbearable she decides to
eat her own placenta oh my god oh which
she had pres okay as night descends Mia
hears The Haunting calls of whales oh
she tries to remain silent but when a
whale collides with the container she
tumbles frightening the baby and causing
her to cry in an effort to ward off the
whale Mia strikes the container wall
with a wooden panel making loud noises
it's her sixth day in the container and
Mia again continues to work on creating
an opening in the ceiling unfortunately
her only tool the pen knife also breaks
furthermore her phone is still not
working and the clean drinking water
also runs out to quench her thirst she
begins licking water drops from the
ceiling but it's clearly not enough
later Mia begins to experience
hallucinations too bad she didn't know
that placenta is All the Rage with
hippie teens these days she sees her
elder daughter accusing her for
abandoning her but Nico also appears and
assures Mia that it's not her fault a
short while later Mia snaps out from her
semiconscious State and notices that
it's raining she quickly arranges some
plastic boxes to collect the water and
also sips some to quench her thirst
after this Mia uses the crate ropes to
pull away a piece of the container's
metal finally revealing the sky above
she then makes her way out of the
container and breathes in the fresh air
she also brings her daughter outside
allowing the baby to enjoy some
freshness as well however the troubling
thing is that there is an Endless Sea on
all sides with no land in sight shortly
after Mia changes her baby's diaper and
throws the dirty one in the water
littering come on this attracts some
fish which gives her hopes of obtaining
food Mia then constructs a makeshift
tool and tries to catch the fish but
sadly her efforts are in vain as she's
unable to hit any of them after multiple
attempts she finally gives up at that
moment she spots an airplane passing
overhead reacting swiftly she hurries
down the container and grasps a piece of
a TV screen to reflect the sunlight but
being in a hurry she ends up injuring
her leg on the sharp edge of the hatch
to make matters worse the airplane also
leaves without noticing her in the next
scene Mia gets down on the container and
uses TV wires and metal pieces to stitch
up her wound the process is so painful
that she falls unconscious at times but
she somehow manages to complete it
during the night time she begins weaving
together the earphone wires by morning
she successfully makes a fishing net
which she then uses to catch fish after
a long time of Hunger Mia finally enjoys
the raw fish from that day onward she
catches fish and stores them in plastic
boxes for her timely meals apart from
all this she also writes SOS notes keeps
them in plastic boxes and releases them
into the sea hoping that someone will
see them one night Mia shows some family
pictures to her daughter and names her
Noah after talking to the baby for a
while both of them fall asleep at
midnight Mia awakens to the sound of
something that's hitting the container
She carries the baby and slowly climbs
up only to discover that it's a plastic
box it's always a plastic box in this
movie at the same time she receives a
call from Nico and she's delighted to
hear his voice but unfortunately he has
bad news he says that he tried to steal
a boat to escape but he was spotted by
the soldiers and got shot he is
currently hiding in a container and
losing a lot of blood Nico apologizes to
Mia saying that he won't be able to make
it and that she has to fight for herself
and their baby Mia is devastated but
shares the news of their daughter's
birth in response n bits a final goodbye
to Mia and Noah before passing away once
more Mia's hope shatters and she breaks
down in tears she then spends the rest
of the night gazing at the sky the scene
fast forwards then today 26 and the
container is half submerged in water Mia
is at the top of the container with her
baby she is constructing a makeshift
raft using materials from the container
during this she notices a seagull which
gives her hope of rescue as the night
falls Mia gets her raft ready and puts
her baby in it suddenly she hears a
sound within the container and learns
that it'll sink soon as a result she
Dives down to retrieve her belongings
she notices that the chocolate given to
her by her husband is floating in the
corner she then swims toward it but
unfortunately her leg gets Tangled in
some ropes the container starts sinking
as Mia struggles to free herself but at
the last moment she manages to cut the
rope and swims up as Mia resurfaces she
panics when she doesn't see her baby
just then a whale passes by and expels
some water on the baby prompting her to
cry that's one way to find a baby Mia
hears the crying voice and swims towards
Noah the next morning Mia who is
completely exhausted throws the fish she
had captured hoping to attract some
birds in this weakened State she talks
to Noah claiming that she did everything
she could at the same time a fishing
boat is casting Nets in the area a
fisherman and his family notices a
seagull surrounding something the family
sails closer only to discover the raft
with the child they quickly pull the
raft up and right then notice a rope
attached to it they pull on it until
Mia's body comes out the rescue group
then brings her aboard the boat and
immediately begins performing CPR
initially Mia doesn't react but the
continuous chest compressions bring her
back to life upon regaining
Consciousness her first concern is for
her baby whom the fisherman's wife
gently hands to her it takes some time
for Mia to realize that she's safe and
she tear is well up as she sees that
they're approaching the shores of
Ireland subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching